Hi everyone! Welcome to our videos about conservation.
Today I am going to be telling you about preventive conservation.
What is preventive conservation?
to be telling you about preventive conservation.
What is preventive conservation? It is what
we do in the museum to take care of the specimens
and objects that we have so that researchers
can use them in the future and so that all
of you can enjoy them when you visit the museum.\
And what do we do when we do preventive conservation?
We take a look at the ten agents of deterioration.
I am not going to tell you about the ten,
but I am going to tell you about a few. For
example, the light that shines on us all the
time or the sun and all that, can be very
problematic for collections, so we look at
visible light and ultraviolet light. When
we go to the beach or we are exposed to the
sun, our skin can become red after a while
of being exposed to the sun, but, the specimens
do not, obviously, have their skins become
red, and what can happen to them is that they
can start to bleach or they may start to have
color problems and they change these colors,
for example, on their feathers or the colors
in the textiles and all that. So, in preventive
conservation we use some things like this
device that I have here, called an Elsec,
and it looks like an old cell phone, but it
is not an old cell phone... What we do is
monitor, with these two monitors here, light,
for example, visible light. There it is telling
us that we have 621 lux, which is fine for
a lab, because it helps us see what we are
doing and working with the specimens. And
we can also monitor ultraviolet light. The
UV light is under 60, which is great. If we
have more than 75 it is a problem for the
specimens, so the values
we have now mean that these specimens can
be here in the laboratory for a long time
and have no problems.\
Other things we have to take care of are temperature
and humidity, which we can also measure with
this fantastic little device. If I show you,
for example, the humidity, we are at less
than 55% and the temperature is around 71
Fahrenheit, so, these two numbers
are also good values
for the specimens, and they allow us to be
with them in the laboratory for a good time.
If we have very high temperatures and very
high humidity, what happens is that things
begin to degrade very quickly, so in the museum
we always try to have temperatures and humidity
that are not only not high, but also without
fluctuations, because if there are fluctuations,
that's when we start to have problems.\
And another thing that I am also going to
show you, is that we also have to clean the
specimens, so, when you have vacuum cleaners
in your house, you have more or less these
elements to use in the vacuum cleaners, but
we in the museum have others that I am going
to show you, that they are very adorable.
Look at the difference in size between the
brushes that we use in our homes and those
that we use in museum conservation. So, these
brushes are great because they are super delicate
and do not affect any of the specimens when
we are using the vacuum cleaner. I am not
going to turn on the vacuum cleaner now because
it makes a lot of noise, but I am going to
show you how we also clean the specimens with
other elements such as, for example, these
sponges, which are very similar to makeup
sponges that you can buy in pharmacies. And
here we have here a horse skull that was on
display in the Mammal Hall until very recently
in the museum and now is in the lab with me,
so I am going to show you... first, of course,
we have to put on gloves before touching any
specimens... I'm going to show you more or
less how we do to cleaning.
So here you see this area that has a lot of
dust. I'm going to come with this little sponge
and I'm going to start slowly. Look at the
difference after having passed the sponge
super slowly. Look at this, this is not very
happy. But well, this is the process that
we have to do in conservation, which is done
very slowly, very calmly, so that none of
the specimens are damaged. So, here is a demonstration
of what we can do to take care of the specimens
in the museum, be it with the temperature,
with the humidity, with the light, with the
dust, and a lot of other things that we also
do to take care of the specimens.
Do not miss the next videos that we are going
to have, which are cleaning and repairing
of feathers in taxidermy birds, and also of
bone. Thank you very much, see you later!
(Music)